we'll give the toast at her own wedding
I do and yes there is shrimp in the egg
rolls downtown people close to the clubs
I thought you wanted to be a cool chick
I could be a cool chick with a doorman
and a Calvin ADA foodarama refrigerator
cancer yes you can
[Music]
[Music]
Joe left you what did you - did you
everything he was supposed to be
something and you and you suddenly
realize you're not yes Mary
[Music]
I was a great wife I was fun
I can't believe I'm losing him - penny
[Music]
sorry but look at me who wouldn't want
to come home to this every night and I
gotta tell you right clubs okay twice
have I seen someone deliver the goods
are you talking about how much her act I
am a mother I don't have an act and you
will when we're done uptown chick got
arrested doing a set simulating a sex
act while on stage mrs. Mason she's
gonna do what with the lights
sit around all day long eating bonbons
except would you want for her of course
not
this comedy thing it has to work one
week with my grandmother's two girls and
[ __ ] my boy
[Applause]
you charge for pictures now
there's something here about miming a
[ __ ] tickling a man's testicles oh I do
yeah she did was [ __ ] funny
you